-Our next guest represents
New York's
14th Congressional District
in the House of Representatives.
Please welcome back to the show
Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, it is so lovely
to have you here.
-Lovely to be here.
Thank you.
-And it seems like
we planned this,
but this has been scheduled
for a long time.
No one could have imagined
a couple of months ago
what happened today.
How does this feel?
How are you processing it
as a New Yorker?
-Yeah, well, I mean,
there's as an American
and as a New Yorker.
As a New Yorker, it was
a very New York kind of day.
You have not just
what was happening
with former President Trump,
but then you have MTG
flying into town.
You've got, you know, just
the whole chaos of the scene
and also all the people
walking by like,
"Okay. I'm on my lunch break.
It's time to go."
-Yeah.
-It's -- You know --
It was -- It was just a lot.
It was a circus, right?
-I mean, your whole life,
this is a person who,
especially in New York,
has been investigated,
never charged.
Multiple --
certainly accusations
of financial improprieties.
Did you ever think
this day would come
where he would be arraigned,
especially for things like,
you know, the misuse of money?
-Yeah, I mean, I --
I think I had always felt
that something might happen.
Honestly,
I think if something did,
I would have thought it would be
something like this,
around falsification of business
documents or some sort of charge
that has to do with
documentation or finances.
But, I mean,
my dad was an architect.
He worked in construction
and in that industry.
And from the time
I was a kid,
it's like no one knew this guy
better than New Yorkers.
And just, like,
this is just --
People would have thought
this is what
he would have been in for
before he was president.
-Yeah.
-So, you know, I think it does
feel like a matter of course.
I also think that --
I mean, listen.
This is not about guaranteeing
one outcome or another.
This is about due process,
and the lack of process of,
I think, a formal due process
for so long
really created this question of,
do we really have
an equal society,
no matter your income,
no matter how powerful you are?
And I think the presence
of this process demonstrates
that we should have one law
that applies to all people,
no matter who you are
or where you come from.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A very true statement.
And also, look.
This is the process.
He's innocent
until proven guilty.
And you were talking
a little backstage
about how there is oftentimes
a hesitation,
both in legal circles
and in politics,
not to move forward unless
you're certain of the outcome.
-Mm-hmm. Yeah. Yeah.
And I think -- I do. I see this
in a legislative context.
Sometimes you see this
in a legal context,
which is we don't want to try
unless we know what the outcome
is before we start, right?
We don't want to hold
a vote on something
unless we know for sure
that it's going to pass.
We know that --
You know, the question.
There's been so much legal
speculation over the last week.
Is this a good idea?
Is it not a good idea?
If we -- If there is evidence
for a crime,
which is what
Alvin Bragg has asserted,
and put before a grand jury
and before a jury
of one's peers,
they themselves move forward
with an indictment,
then this is the process
that must happen in our society.
And then, once again,
there will be another jury
of their peers
to convict or acquit.
But we should not make
these decisions
solely on whether you know
that you're guaranteed
to be successful from the start.
I think people need
to see these charges
or see just charges
where there is evidence for it.
And I believe that, you know,
the presence of that due process
is what makes our system fair.
It's a consequence
in and of itself.
And I think it's important.
I just think it's important.
-You mentioned Alvin Bragg.
Three GOP House chairs
basically wrote to him
demanding that he come
and testify,
that he bring documents
from this investigation.
It seems like the office hit
back pretty strongly to that.
How do you feel about sort of
the members of Congress
reaching out and trying
to interfere
in an investigation like this?
-Yeah, I mean,
I think what they've attempted
to do,
whether it's Jim Jordan
or Chairman Comer
in House Oversight,
where I sit, there needs
to be clear jurisdiction.
And what we have seen from
House Republicans especially
is that they seem to have
interpreted their role
as just defending and working
for Donald Trump,
sometimes more than working
for the kinds of people
that they've been
elected to serve.
You know, we're seeing
more energy for defending
former President Trump than for
passing gun-safety legislation,
from helping health care,
from people in, you know --
from what happened
in the spill in, you know --
I think what we need to see
is an actual government
that works for people,
no matter what party
you're a part of,
instead of which partisan person
you're most loyal to.
-I think that's --
They should also know...
[ Applause ]
When you work for Donald Trump,
you often don't get paid.
And that's something
they should keep in mind.
You questioned Michael Cohen.
This was a few years back.
This was your first year. You
were a freshman congresswoman.
And you talked to him
about the inflation of assets.
This was a different thing
that Donald Trump did for years.
He would -- Basically, if he was
counting it as an asset,
he would say
it was worth this much.
And if he was paying taxes
on it, he would maybe lower it.
And this actually led --
Tish James has mentioned you
and mentioned that questioning
as leading
to a separate civil case
against Donald Trump.
It's so interesting because
I feel like a lot of times
you watch people
grandstand in moments
where they get to
question someone.
You laid out -- very simple,
in a way
that people like even I
could understand.
Do you feel like
people in Congress
miss the opportunity
to take their time
and lay something out
very clearly
for the American people
to understand?
-Yeah, you know, I, um --
I actually recently --
So, my first year,
I also held this
kind of Twitter seminar
for some of my colleagues.
And this year, I worked with
some of my other colleagues,
including folks like
Maxine Waters and Madeleine Dean
on also kind of teaching folks
how to use your five minutes
most effectively.
I think, you know --
When we talk about
what your member
of Congress does,
it's not just legislate.
Our job is to investigate.
And that is a core element
of our duties, to pursue that.
And so I do think --
It takes a lot of preparation.
It's kind of like
what Mark Twain said.
"This letter would be shorter,
but I didn't have time."
That brevity takes an enormous
amount of preparation.
I kind of look like that scene
from "It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia"
with the guy like this.
-All the yarn connecting...
-All the yarn.
That's what my desk looks like
during a hearing sometimes.
You have to work with
what's happening midstream.
But I think it's very powerful.
It's really important.
And our job is to educate
and communicate to the public,
in addition to legislating.
-I want to talk about other
legislation you're working on.
Before we go to commercial,
Trump was supposedly stuck on
FDR after the arraignment today.
Is that the most perfect
New York punishment for...?
-Okay.
I have to take issue
because I represent
LaGuardia Airport.
-I told you. It's nice now.
-Okay?
-We put a lot of work into that.
-And I'm telling you.
It is great.
I'm a huge fan of LaGuardia now.
It's just hard for us as comedy
writers. You took someth--
This would be like if
the Mets won the World Series.
-I know.
-What would we do?
What would we joke about?
What I will say is
that I do think it was an omen
that he landed
in my congressional district.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah. I think --
-Show him who's boss!
-There you go.
We'll be right back
with more from Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.